you got one of my questions there's
something I want to spend some time
talking about in terms of smart
contracts zero knowledge proves all of
these kind of ancillary pieces of
technology or concepts that are you know
being explored by other cryptocurrencies
or crypto assets you think eventually
get contributed back to Bitcoin as long
as they have value and sustainability -
yes and it's already happened
right so on on smart contracts the
rootstock team has been a few years
exploring this and and there's other
teams exploring side-chains to do smart
contracts Eric Martindale at
yeah fabric on working on fabric is
working on a potential layer I guess we
could call it layer three solution to
you know building more complex scripting
into Bitcoin and so that that's already
happening to an extent and I think the
further Bitcoin monetizes it's actually
going to be increasingly relevant
there's actually another sort of
reframing here because when I say you
know hey people are working on this
stuff the pushback I often get is well
all the DAPs are still being built
elsewhere and the reality is that people
don't want to waste their time right
people I think largely people in the
Bitcoin sort of developed in the
universe of you know say roughly 500
2000 people of which there are probably
50 or 70 50 75 really regular
contributors to directly to Bitcoin and
and you know besides that contribution
base there's you know thousands of
people who work or who are building on
Bitcoin or built in or building services
that have to interface with Bitcoin
directly you know these people don't
like to waste their time right there's
only so many of them in the world I
think that what they're focused on
building right now is the most secure
protocol that is most conservative in
its assumptions that is most safe in its
sort of method of operation and whatever
else is important you know we'll let the
market you know dictate what is
important and kind of incorporate
downstream there are a number of on the
privacy side I think one of the things
that's been really interesting is this
sort of Bitcoin development culture
where what it actually forces is a lot
of the innovation that is that would be
on like a base layer chain to be moved
downstream and so on the on the privacy
angle a lot of the interesting things
that people are working on on privacy
they're sort of like improvements on
coin join or other mixers samurai Wallet
I find really compelling as a project
they have an Android app but haven't
released on iOS yet and so a lot of the
privacy components being moved to the
transaction layer or you know a
different layer I think is pretty
compelling in the Indy short to
medium-term future I am pretty happy
with the privacy projects that are out
there particularly cash and Manero both
of which use different privacy
mechanisms I've been monitoring the
launch of grin pretty closely which will
launch later this year early next year
which is another kind of non another
anonymous fare mind interesting privacy
project and so I think that privacy is
still something that's very important
for you know Bitcoin users and Bitcoin
developers and the community of original
cypherpunks that a primarily bitcoin is
coalesced around I've seen demos of
different I don't want to name names but
I've seen demos of different chain
analysis tools and they are terrifying
man I think that why well they're
terrifying because I think the logical
implication of a lot of people focused
on on chain analysis do you know despite
the fact that it is still a little bit
rudimentary there's a lot of information
to clean I think that will quickly move
to a future where if bitcoin is not
fungible it's not fully fungible we're
gonna have a whole we're gonna have
different types of Bitcoin right we're
gonna have clean Bitcoin we're gonna
have dirty Bitcoin and it will trade at
different rates and I think that that's
not what we want in Bitcoin I think we
want a fully functional Bitcoin the same
way you know gold is largely fungible
you know cash it has I guess it has an
identification in the in the form of
serial numbers but
you know direct transferrin cashes
directly you know it's it's directly
fungible and you know that's part of the
reason why you know drug dealers and
terrorists often use US dollars right
they use cash it's their choice of
currency yeah shout out shout out Jamie
Dimon he was wrong about that and and so
I actually really do worry about a
future where Bitcoin isn't fully
fungible and and do you think that will
fungibility is something that Bitcoin
developers are pretty concentrated on
and it's something that's improved
substantially over time and there's a
number of proposals for different you
know everything from different signature
types to you know full scale Ryoka
textures but I think any sort of
large-scale privacy would be many years
down line but in the short to medium
term there are a lot of efforts focus on
fungibility that I find compelling